uh hello there steve here again
uh i have a bit of a cold so if i sneeze
uh several times during this video uh
please excuse me i'm going to talk about
pronunciation and the importance of
pronunciation
and i'm going to refer to an article
which i
saw put out by the
physics org or whatever at any rate it
says fluency outweighs pronunciation for
understanding non-native english
speakers so a study was done and they
found
that people who speak english as a
second language were more likely to be
judged as easy to understand when they
spoke with fluency regardless of the
accuracy of their pronunciation okay now
that does doesn't just apply to
non-native speakers of english
the key in language is communication
so
therefore
the key for pronunciation is also
communication can you be understood
i have experienced many times
both
the
sense of respect for someone who speaks
with an accent even a heavy accent but
who puts words together accurately
correctly precisely
naturally
uses
you know
a wide vocabulary natural phrasing but
does so with an accent
that person i understand and i have
respect for on the other hand i have
experienced people who have quite good
pronunciation but who use very unnatural
phrasing you know lots of gunawana
uh trying to be very
native-like but don't make sense in
other words they don't communicate very
well
and
while in this particular article they
talk about fluency as being more
important than pronunciation in order to
be fluent in order for the words to flow
together they have to be
used accurately the way the native
speaker uses those words in combination
with other words to express different
situations
if the person says i am interesting in
music
the native speaker is put off because
it's i'm interested in music if as so
many people say
even it is raining i won't take an
umbrella people are put off because it's
not an accurate use of that expression
it's even if or even though
and so there are many other other
examples like this that the correct
usage
which translates into fluency you can't
be fluent if you aren't
fairly accurate you don't have to be a
hundred percent accurate but you have to
be fairly accurate in your use of the
language
again in my view
not so much
in terms of the odd missing s
or the odd missing article in english
which doesn't bother me i can understand
i have russian employees one very
um
capable programmer who communicates very
well communicates his ideas very well
but he's not prone to use the article
because in russian there are no articles
that doesn't matter but he uses his
words accurately the key words are used
accurately and he speaks fluently and he
speaks with an accent and he has no
inhibitions and he's a very effective
communicator so
to summarize
i heartily support the findings of this
report that's
very much my experience
to try
of course as a matter of vanity we would
always like to be able to pronounce as
closely as possible to the way a native
speaker pronounces that's our model
and some of us will get closer to that
model and some of us will not get quite
as close and some of us may not get
close at all and as long as you're able
to communicate as long as people
understand you as long as you can
achieve a degree of fluency in the
language
which requires a fairly large vocabulary
depending on what you're talking about
of course if all you wanted if you're a
mom taking her kid to school and wants
to chit chat with the other moms you may
not need such a large vocabulary but if
you are working and
you're socializing with people and a
great range of subjects might come up
you also need a large vocabulary all
those things are more important than
trying to imitate
native pronunciation i mean imitate it
yes but don't have the expectation that
you're going to achieve it if you like
some people like lucca the famous luca
who is extremely good at imitating
native like pronunciation if you can do
that good
but if you don't
equally good in my opinion so there you
have it pronunciation versus vocabulary
fluency and so forth and i will put a
link to this article in the description
and i also mentioned it
on my blog thanks for listening bye for
now